okay where right now new york city why
the salt conference starts in about an
hour now this conference is all about
crypto but some of the panels
at this year's conference are all about
what is the regulator going to do where
are we going with bitcoin what's
happening with land and all these
protocols that have been blocked so far
by regulators yet at the same time the
opportunity is if regulators allow
cryptocurrencies and allow all these new
protocols around different coins and
stable coins etc the potential is
explosive there's at least a trillion
dollars worth of buying waiting just to
go into bitcoin alone if the regulator
would approve an approve an etf which
they haven't done yet the world has come
to new york to talk about
cryptocurrencies and the future of
payment systems and decentralized
finance who doesn't want to be here plus
it's a parte
[Music]
and last but not least we have kevin
o'leary who is
many of you probably already know is the
um
co-host of shark tank um but also has
become a recent convert into the
cryptocurrency space and has um is the
primary investor in a platform called
wonder five which aims to bring
defy uh to the masses so really a
fantastic panel as a bit of a cultural
icon yourself
um what brought you to crypto it seems
that
this wasn't something you were always
bought in on what changed your mind and
what makes you excited about this space
you know i was a
very vocal uh
non-advocate
in back in 2017 because i i i'm forced
to live in a world i service pension
funds and institutions with indexing
we we are 100 compliant 100 of the time
and my first purchase was not in our
operating company i just bought some
ethereum and some bitcoin in a wallet
myself back in 2017
and one day just talked about it in the
in on you know on television on business
press
and my compliance officer called me up
while i was still in the green room
saying are you out of your mind are you
out of your mind
you know we cannot have this dialogue
and because we're going to get a call
and sure enough we did and
what's changed is the regulatory
environment because
i don't have the option to be
non-compliant i don't even have that at
all
but
slowly and surely in other jurisdictions
first switzerland germany france
australia england canada which has
allowed etfs now with with uh ethereum
and with bitcoin
so i changed when the regulator changed
and i'm very interested in crypto now as
an asset class and in my world let's say
um
let's say you're running a a billion
dollar mandate which is a typical
mutual fund or etf or whatever and
generally if you're compliant with your
own compliant department they'll there's
11 sectors in the s p for example
you're allowed to go up to 20 anyone
sector and up to 5 in any one name
that's generally how it works
i argue today that crypto is the 12th
sector of the s p that's what it is it
doesn't mean i have to have everything
in bitcoin and i don't want to have
everything in bitcoin i want to have a
portfolio of crypto coin
chain
you know tokens whatever is compliant
and what's going to happen here and what
what we need to do and why i'm so happy
we have these dialogues in these
conferences
think about
the typical institution every night at
401 they mark to market every position
they have the internal compliance
department sees it how much leverage is
used what the positions are is it within
mandate not over five percent whatever
it is
then their external auditors
come in on a weekly or quarterly or
annual basis and sign those auditing
statements then they issue that report
to the regulator
we don't have that infrastructure in
crypto right now there's on this stage
there's two guys trying to do it sam at
ftx and jeremy here at uh with circle
and i'm definitely involved with both of
them because i want to be getting that
but it took me months just to get my
first purchase done
on circle with my own compliance
department barking at me like a dog
saying no no no we can't do this and i'm
saying we've got to do it we've got to
get there we have to figure it out and
my auditor and the regulator reports we
have put out and it's working same with
sam i want to build a portfolio on ftx
you know because it's big enough
that i can be compliant it's
i'm the and i'm saying everybody on this
if we solve this there's trillions of
dollars coming into this in the 12
sector the s p that's what it's going to
be so that's our job we got to solve for
compliance it's boring but it really
matters
somehow over the last
i don't know two years
um the popular press positioned the
crypto community as an adversary to
regulators globally
and that's simply not true and it's very
stupid because
probably some large percentage of the
constituency in this room is somehow
tied to financial institutions one way
or another and we have not even tapped
it's so nascent there's so many
institutions that don't even play in
this space although although they want
to
and the primary reason is their
compliance departments and the tone of
that relationship
between the crypto community and the
regulator and every week we hear another
case of
somebody in
you know in in a position of of of uh
power let's call it that that's running
a large uh crypto
company
striking out at the regulator
really bad idea like there is
zero upside in that because the
the regulator wants to solve for this
because this and i'll say it again it's
going to be the 12th sector the s p
there's no question about it it's not
going away and the demand is huge
the tone should be that of accommodating
their concerns i'll give you a case
study this nft investment i'm making in
watches
is it a security
or is it a piece of art
i can't go forward till it's resolved i
can't just throw it out there and start
trading it all over the place not
knowing that outcome and so
i
i'm willing to reach out
uh as an advocate to that one little
sliver of nfts and say to the regulator
give me guidance let's work together and
if it is security tell me i'm good i'm
good with it i will treat it that way
i'm not fighting you on it just give me
the rules so i can play football you
can't play football without the rules
and that's where we're at here and the
upside to solving this problem
is trillions of dollars of assets that
will
pour into this you want to see bitcoin
at a hundred thousand dollars you gotta
let the regulator determine what terms
they'll allow it to go into an uh
an etf it's that simple look what
happened in canada they got a billion
dollars demand in a matter of hours
in just the first bitcoin product and it
wasn't even institutional
it was just simply retail saying oh must
be safe
i can buy it and put it in my my account
online and the regulator said it's okay
so my thing is
as a as a community we have to
form a lobby voice and say we are here
to serve
and protect just like you are give us
the rules so we can go back and play
football that's simple
so what is your prediction for where we
will be 10 years from now
it's going to change everything
let me tell you one of the reasons that
i'll make it short and sweet
let's say a traditional mandate such as
i want to go long europe i'm going to
buy 50 stocks i have to buy swiss francs
euro base stocks and british pounds
because i want to trade them on their
domestic exchanges
in between me and that transaction is
what's called the bane of the earth the
fx trader the currency trader who clips
me
every time i buy and sell adds
zero value
zero value and sucks friction out of the
system and has my entire adult life as
i've traded in europe
i can't wait until we solve this problem
and give them a new career shining shoes
because they add no value whatsoever
this is where d5 can take us on just one
use case
but it's a multi-billion dollar one and
i want to be alive to have a regulator
domestically allow me a payment system
to a swiss franc back and forth if i
want to trade it 50 times a day with
zero fx traders
that's my mission in life to help them
find a real job
people ask me all the time what's my
opinion on taxation of crypto and should
it be legal tender let's regulate it
because there's so much pent-up demand
to buy it once the regulators approve it
i don't care if it gets taxed that's
okay
if it has to be a currency where you
make money you pay tax in most
jurisdictions that happens with multiple
asset classes why shouldn't it happen
with crypto we don't have the compliance
platform yet to actually do the
reporting you need for that but that's
coming too so the answer is let's
regulate it let's get it approved by
regulators and all the different
jurisdictions around the world and yes
if you profit from it and that's the
jurisdiction that taxes you pay your
taxes what are you whining about you
just made money
what about bitcoin etfs that's still
something that has not been approved in
the united states i know you're a big
etfc guy do you see that
going through eventually in the united
states and this goes to our earlier
conversation about regulation it's been
kind of it's been slow in the united
states
i don't see it getting resolved i don't
see the first etf coming until we have
the regulatory environment to approve it
and also we've solved the sg issue
so
the answer is no time soon people that
are thinking it's coming this year are
wildly optimistic it won't
people think it's coming next year also
also too optimistic i'm thinking go to
the canadian exchange and which
you can do it's compliant in canada but
i think the real opportunity and another
trillion dollars with the buying would
be when we get a us-based etf for both
ethereum maybe another chain
in an etf
i'm a huge fan of the team
uh we just recently took it public a
couple of weeks ago investors are very
happy with outcomes and it's just the
beginning and i'm proud to be here
representing them
um love it a shout out to honey by the
way jamie um
you know i'm an investor i'm up about
sixty one point two percent but who's
counting
down a round of
in applause 2021
the real business is done right now
schmoozing
this is where you get stuff done i love
the panels i participate in all of them
but you want to get deals done
right now right here the shoe is fast if
you like that video wait did you see my
next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe